I just could I just couldn't I just
could never say like I wouldn't say
you're perfect
yeah yeah and that's and that's what I
mean I'm just playing around
I'm a 10 out of 10. yeah I take care of
myself what has given you that uh my
looks we were only talking about look we
weren't talking about personality or
skill or anything like that is is that
based on the way people have treated you
throughout your life no this is based on
how I was raised and how I view myself
and how I've worked hard to see the
beauty that I deserve to see so I worked
so you see an 11 out of 10 Beauty I
wouldn't bro it's a joke dog okay okay
but we could say 10 things yeah like I
just said I consider myself a 10 out of
10 for sure so you think you're up there
with so who would you see in like the
media that's like a 10 out of 10 why are
we going based off of media people why
does that matter well because because
it's on society